[Music]
they are the crystal gems and they
always save the day Steven universe is
one of those odd shows you just can't
stop watching but even this show comes
with plenty of moments that weren't for
kids after all if every pork chop were
perfect we wouldn't have hot dogs stay
tuned to find out which episode has the
most inappropriate moments and censored
scenes give this video a thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe to our Channel
now let's check out 10 Steven universe
episodes that weren't for kids coach
Steven coach Steven is the 20th episode
of season one and to be honest it's just
a weird one we all know amethyst is a
very energetic character but she's not
exactly a good role model for Steven yet
alone the people who are watching the
show in coach Steven the team has to
come up with a plan to destroy the
crystal gem communication hub which is
releasing bursts of electromagnetic
interference steven of course doesn't
get it and garnet explains at the Havas
hurting television which is the only way
she can get him to participate in
helping out it definitely shows Steven
as a lazy character and even though we
all know kids love to sit and watch TV
no parent would want them to watch this
episode but that's not the only reason
why this episode isn't for children
after pearl says they need to be careful
garnet replies they just need to be huge
this seems to make Steven very excited
but when he tries to watch garnet and
amethyst break out in their weird
synchronized dance pearl covers his eyes
which means he's definitely watching
something he shouldn't and neither
should the kids who are watching this
show peril definitely looks
uncomfortable when she covered Stevens
eyes while amethyst and garnet got busy
and we have to say the scene made us
just a little bit uncomfortable alone
together Steven universe has often been
criticized for being one of the weirdest
shows ever which is precisely why we
think adults might appreciate this show
more than kids
it's full of innuendos and scenes that
would go way over any child's heads like
alone together
the 37th episode of the first season in
the very first scenes of the episode we
see the crystal gems try to teach Steven
how to use his fusion powers for the
dancing of course amethyst and Steven
just mess around and get nothing done so
pearl and garnet have to step in to show
him the
way.the to share quite an intimate
moment when garnet somewhat forcefully
pushes pearl against the wall and it
seems like even steven gets completely
fascinated for a brief seconds but then
steven takes over by dancing with pearl
while garnet watches the weird moment
comes when he pushes pearl against the
wall just like garnet did earlier he's
half pearls height so you can imagine
where his head and eyes land pearl and
garnet share a look but Steven's eyes
never let go of pearl seems like a
pretty awkward moment for a kids show
and of course then there's the whole
talk about fusing and how the crystal
gems phase into each other Steven even
makes a weird hand gesture while
explaining it to Connie these were
definitely moments that were meant for
adults maximum capacity maximum capacity
is the forty third episode of season one
and just like previous episodes it
definitely has some moments that weren't
really meant for kids if you're an adult
we bet you'll be able to figure out some
of these innuendos in a second maximum
capacity is also kind of sad especially
at the beginning when Greg mentions he
hasn't had the time to clear out any of
the storage space since his mom gave
birth to Steven and gave up her physical
form but of course every time an episode
shows amethyst you know weird and
inappropriate things are going to happen
greg clearly gets uncomfortable when he
sees amethyst implying that they have a
history between them this gets confirmed
when amethyst says that it's cool
because she has seen his junk before
needless to say greg looks guilty as
charged when Steven spots a box full of
books he and Greg go through it to see
if they'd be okay for Steven
but then the camera points to a book
called passions of Xander and the cover
of it looks definitely like it's not
meant for kids Greg takes it away laughs
and says they'll have to save that one
for when Steven is a little older unless
a little over kids to watch this show
this episode definitely wasn't supposed
to be seen by children secret team
secret team is these 29th episode of the
first season first of all let's start
with amethyst room we're pretty sure
there are a couple of kids out there
whose rooms pretty much look like this
but there's a moment in the very first
scenes that will be more appreciated by
adults than it would be by kids if you
already saw this episode you probably
giggled at this team Steve
is testing on his cannon balls when
amethyst tells him that he needs to put
more ball in his cannon Stephen of
course gets incredibly confused and
nervously looks down then he asks
amethyst if it'll hurt if you're an
adult
you've probably caught what amethyst
meant by cannon and why Stephen looks so
confused by her statement of course
everything is explained when she turns
into a ball and shows him how it's done
but we have to admit that we did giggle
at a totally unexpected scene that will
probably and hopefully go over most kids
head later on amethyst finds pearl
dancing with rose quartz as gem shards
and the two start fighting because they
both know garnet won't be happy when she
hears about this when Steven gets the
bubble in his hands it of course breaks
it's an important lesson never to take
things that aren't yours and never ever
question the word cannon in a cannon
ball say uncle
say uncle is the twenty-ninth episode of
season 2 it was an April Fool's Day
crossover between Steven universe and a
Cartoon Network series called uncle
grandpa this story revolves around
Steven's long-lost relative coming to
Beach City to help Steven unlock the
power of his mother's gem we love every
cartoon worlds crossover but when you
pair up an odd show with an even odder
show it's clear that the episode wasn't
really bitten for children Uncle grandpa
isn't exactly a popular show but we have
to admit that it gave us plenty of
laughs and giggles but it looks like the
writers of say uncle didn't really think
through just how to bring in uncle
grandpa Steven introduces him to the
rest of his team and of course everyone
questions his relations to Greg pearl
then says that him being an uncle
grandpa would make him Greg's brother
and father - which garnet replies that
it explains a lot of things you wouldn't
think much of this joke as a child but
we've got a couple of adults probably
laughed out loud
especially after knowing how strange
Greg behaved sometimes he's also an
uncle grandpa of everyone in the world
and when he comes around everyone is
going to have a fun time we'd like to
skip on that fun time thank you very
much joking victim the 21st episode of
season one is quite controversial when
it comes to slightly inappropriate
things that aren't meant for kids this
particular scene was even censored in
many countries as its overly dramatic
joking victim is all about Steven
helping out Sadie work the shift at the
big donut Laura's really wants to get
out of his shift and it's pretty obvious
he's really not in pain but Steven
thought to jump in to help as he eats
their Donuts a lot in this episode
steven has his first lesson in work
nepotism when it's clear that he's doing
a much better job than Laura's ever
would and even Sadie agrees but after
talking to Sadie about firing him and
being his replacement Sadie admits that
even though Lars isn't the perfect
employee she likes him and then she
starts explaining how she was banned
from the only store selling a new video
game he wanted so she waited seven hours
in line to get it then she says that he
cleans his room got her a box of oyster
crackers and let her be his player too
she adds that they spend a whole night
together - which Steven replies that it
must have been a long video game
Sadie suddenly looks up from her
daydreaming and awkwardly replies that
it was knowing she could be totally
caught if Steven was an adult did you
catch her inappropriate story Tiger
millionaire Tiger millionaire is a lot
of fun for those who love boxing but we
have a feeling many parents would agree
that this episode is a bit too violent
for kids it all starts out with Steven
being covered in weird junk which gets
harder and harder over time during this
time amethyst gets criticized for well
being amethyst which makes her storm out
she later comes back at night dressed in
a coat and had it to a wrestling match
Steven watches into pies as she's
announced as the most hated wrestler
after he confronts her about it she
admits that she's a secret wrestler and
Steven of course begs her to join in
he also mocks his fellow team members
after he tries to convince em ah--this
that he also has a lot of anger inside
of him but as you watched the episode
you might find that several of the
scenes were far too violent for kids
steven can't handle some of the comments
about him being the cruelest creature
but then returns to the match we also
don't think that any parent we want
their child to sneak off to a wrestling
match and then there's amethyst
unresolved anger issues that fully come
out especially when she starts fighting
garnet we definitely think this episode
has way too much violence poor garnet so
many birthdays in so many birthdays we
get another look at amethyst mess of a
room while she's definitely a cool chick
we that no parent would want their child
to have a room like hers she even ate a
burrito from a place that closed five
years ago we'll skip Steven's birthday
song and go straight into his question
if birthdays are just for little kids
what an existential question no child
should ask themselves Stephen starts
sulking and then you begin singing
puberty his voice starts changing him he
gets pimples and grows in size he goes
to the arcade where he spent some time
playing the whacking game and he walks
back he says it was fun but a boy on the
cusp of manhood can't spend the whole
day whacking kids probably won't think
much of this sentence but we bet you
giggled when you first heard the word
whacking Stephens right we really can't
spend the whole day wack green and it's
nothing any child should ever know about
Stephen grows by the second and decides
to find a job he picks a shirt that says
professional beach hunk but if you look
in the background of the scene you'll
notice an unintentional shout-out to
iPhones autocorrect special duck off
overall we don't think any child should
go to an existential crisis because of a
single Steven universe episode onion
trade onion trade is all about Stephen
not finding one of the toys Greg got in
last summer this starts off a toy trade
but before we get into that there's an
episode that will make every parent
slightly uncomfortable
everyone notes that Stephen is silky
because he lost the toy and while
amethyst and pearl don't think much of
it his father asks what happened to
break out the bad news Stephen tells
Greg that he lost something precious
Greg gets scared and asked his Stephen
lost his innocence we bet every adult
knows exactly what Stephens dad is
talking about and quite frankly it might
be a joke that's gone a little bit too
far Stephen doesn't think much of it and
continues to tell how he lost one of his
guys toys he likes so much just because
his dad gave it to him it seems as
Stephen is completely heartbroken
because his dad doesn't even remember
the special Ranger guy that is until
Greg hands him a bag of quarters to go
get another one which turns into him
following around onion well we're quite
glad all Stephen lost was his toys and
not his innocence it's safe to say that
joke went a little bit too far although
it definitely wasn't censored like our
last Steven universe moment onion friend
if there is a Steven universe episode
that has way too many inappropriate
jokes and censored scenes
it's definitely onion friends it's the
13th episode of season 2 and it's
definitely one of those we can't watch
more than once it's all about Stephen
and amethyst visiting onions house after
onion stills
even's bag of maximum barbecue chaps
after Stephen comes into onions garage
he notices that it's basically a shrine
to amethyst and calls him over the to
get caught but amethyst recognizes
onions mother and it's implied that the
two spent a lot of time with Greg and
then started hanging out by themselves
which implies something kids probably
won't register after Padilla asked
Stephen if they still look the same as
their old pictures
amethyst says that she's wearing old
people slippers but the Dahlia fires
back that she has no idea what she's
done in those shoes which is yet another
innuendo amethyst also asked if a Dahlia
still hears from old farty Marty and for
some reason the UK version of the show
censored that name after hanging out at
their bizarre house onion shows Steven
and videotape tiled happy birthday onion
it turns out to be onions actual birth
video which is absolutely creepy and yet
another reason to label this episode as
too inappropriate for children and
that's it for our video for more videos
like this one check out ten rumors about
descendants three you need to hear see
you next time
[Music]